ils sont là on va parler bien sûr de ce
partenariat transpacifique encore parce
que je ne veux pas ça à était
l'essentiel un enjeu important dans
cette campagne électorale aujourd'hui à
l'aide qu'on a vu monsieur rap lula qui
a voulu rassurer les travailleurs de
l'ontario l'automobile en pointe là on
oublie pohlad
hier on avait la compensation pour les
agriculteurs sachant que pour la gestion
de la faune allait avoir des cris
indignés c'est important ça se préparait
depuis un moment puis évidemment le
secteur automobile us y ait des gens qui
sont insatisfaits donc on est allé faire
une annonce aujourd'hui dans le sud de
l'ontario lho incidemment de membres qui
avaient passé toute la journée dimanche
assisté par affaire six circonscriptions
justement dans les régions importantes
pour l'industrie automobile donc ont été
ré annoncé le milliard de l'arbed c'est
un peu un aveu aussi par la bande qui
est des secteurs qui vont être touchés
par ce type de partenariat qui va avoir
des emplois qui vont être perdus qu'on
leur donne une compensation pour essayer
de se renouveler tirer leur épingle du
jeu donc si ce que stephen harper mais
il le savait depuis un bon moment le qui
allait avoir dans certains secteurs des
gens très insatisfaits puis visiblement
on avait préparé le terrain du côté des
conservateurs qu'un élément important
arrive dans une campagne les chefs bien
sûr les parties doivent se positionner
sur mulcair a choisi chantal très
clairement d'être con j'aurais pu me
suis réveillée très très peu tu trudeau
il n'est pas contre du touladi j'attends
de voir les détails attendez-vous parce
que monsieur traders disent je suis pour
à la vie à la mort où je suis contre
d'ici aux élections puisque sa position
ces deux fronts un débat et le débat
sera plus large que simplement les
députés de la chambre des communes
quand on avait des vrais textes en
mairie mais le parti libéral et pro
libre échange d'ailleurs je fais
remarquer parce que peu de gens en ont
parlé mais le bloc québécois d'hier qui
était très déçu par ce qui arrive et
possiblement la gestion de l'offre
mais moi je suis allé lire le communiqué
trois fois là il disait pas une comme
monsieur mannequin nous allons votre
groupe
il disait on n'est pas prêt à dire qu'on
va voter pour ce qui est profondément
différent je veux souvenirs monsieur
apparu en interview hier la première
ministre ontario madame wang il savait
ce point de femmes de stephen harper
ration de combat d'ici un flot remis
pour descendre en flammes les
conservateurs mais elle n'a pas
mentionné l'entente trans pacifique
parce que d'après ce que j'en comprends
le gouvernement libéral de l'ontario est
plutôt d'accord avec l'entente
vous avez raison pour le bloc d'ailleurs
on en a parlé avec denis ferland tout à
l'heure le bloc qui reprend la tradition
québécoise est ouvert aux accords de
libre-échange bien sûr on se soucie du
sort des fermes laitières en oui mais
faut pas oublier le bloc va commencer
cette campagne là avec des slogans comme
qui prend pays prend partie parce que il
voulait aller chercher la base
souverainiste ils sont allés la chercher
s'ils veulent et cherchait donc voir
faut qu'ils aillent chercher quelque
chose qui ressemble au consensus de
l'assemblée nationale qui se faisaient
très fort de défendre une certaine
époque
consciencieuse l'assemblée nationale fut
criant ils se déchirent pour la cheville
sur cette entente là bien au contraire
alors oui a dit il ya des choses dans le
dans l'industrie de tiers qui plaisent
pas qu'ils pensent pas actuellement
mais il ya un programme de compensation
en ontario c'est l'industrie automobile
ou savoir-faire probablement plus mal
même que dans l'agriculture
parce que là on parle que tous ceux qui
font des pièces mais des pièces qui sont
à basse valeur ajoutée le des plaquettes
de frein des caoutchoucs autour des
pare-brise et sert à ça ça brille encore
et ça va être fou en chine ça devrait le
faire ailleurs
ce domaine là il va y avoir de la perte
d'emploi est ce pour ça que la
compensation elle est dans le fonds
d'innovation de l'automobile en disant
cela
vous ferez des nouvelles pièces des
logiciels des choses comme valeur
ajoutée valeur ajoutée parce que les
caoutchoucs le sahara mais pour revenir
quelques secondes au bloc quand même il
faut se souvenir que le parti québécois
au pouvoir au moment où on conclu
l'entente canado europe accepte les
concessions sur la gestion de l'offre
qui vont toucher les fromagers parce que
cette entente là est plus importante que
les concessions sur la gestion de
l'offre alors imaginer que monsieur
duceppe qui d'autre part tendance à dire
blancan du npd dit noir et s'adonne que
ça lui permet de respecter son schéma de
couleurs ça tombe bien dans ce que oui
oui le gave une logique là dedans mais
déjà même intéressant parce que vendredi
à tva monsieur duceppe accusé presse que
c'est un apport de vouloir exécuter
c'est fini la gestion de l'offre et ça
va être vous puis notre plan dit tu vois
c'est parce que c'est pas si pire
finalement ou en tout cas je suis pas
prêt à dire que moi je déchire cette
entente
il ya beaucoup de enverra ya pas de
sondages de tommy on imagine que
beaucoup de canadiens qui regarde cette
entente l'indien est ce que vraiment on
aurait pu être à l'extérieur de ce
cercle là et de vouloir aller jouer on
est un pays qui exporte le pays
d'exportation white 35 millions
d'habitants on a besoin d'avoir accès
aux différents marchés
ceci dit ce que tout le monde est
convaincu que stephen harper l'option
optimale est ce qu on a eu vraiment
l'entendre qu'on pouvait le mieux
obtenir sur cette question en europe où
la réponse parce qu'on n'a pas vu les
textes on sait pas vraiment ce qui va
exactement dans les détails
souvenez-vous de l'accord avec l'union
européenne qui ont été annoncés plus
d'une reprise étaient bonnes en faire
s'est même rendu en europe pourraient un
peuple a signé le toujours pas ratifiée
par aucun parlement canadien et aucun
genre allemand et européen et est
toujours pas de texte pourquoi parce
qu'il parle parlement européen qui ont
vu certains détails ce sont des choses
qu'on aime pas là dedans parce que les
négociateurs ont fait il ya des choses
qui positivement on est moins éloquent
de réécrire certaines clauses ce que
l'entente de principe c'est encore avec
l'union européenne on n'est même pas
certain et le j'entendais parler les
démocrates aux états unis même les
républicains comme donald trump qui
aiment pas beaucoup les entendre cet
accord est loin d'être ratifié leur avis
ce pays bristol à paris c'est une tout
autre échelle mais qu'on est quand on
est allé à mitch et que tout le monde
est sorti en chantant on s'est rencontré
au lendemain pour animer ce qu'on avait
convenu en chantant à midi et on a passé
et l'oeil c'est juste nous le canada
tout petit on a passé une nuit sur le
trottoir à attendre que ces gens là
réussissent à accoucher d'un vrai accord
puis il y avait juste cinq points énorme
et je sais pas si sorcier quant à
imaginer les yeux doux ce pays
cela dit oui le vrai joueur si le
président obama qui a fait passer un
fastueux qui tient cette chose là ça
fait partie de son héritage et fassois
que ça veut dire on ne peut pas amendé
le vous pour dit on perd ou on laisse
c'est tout ce qu'on peut faire à partir
de ce moment là quand les etats unis
auront ratifié c'est gratuit bien sûr ça
va aller relativement rapidement
c'est plus facile de passer sur quelles
bases et l'union européenne c'est lui
qui à l'horloge en entrevue très bien
partenariat transpacifique vous avez
peut-être manqué les échanges
aujourd'hui entre le maire colère non il
a nommé son bouquet est ce qu'on l'a
l'extrait je les prends un peu de
compote de monsieur lebel mais du maire
de montréal qui parle non on n'a pas
oublié lui a présenté au début de
l'émission entre eux si on le trouve un
voleur présentés sont là avec les
pierrafeu il accuse le gouvernement
conservateur du ils vont pas nous faire
la morale alors que pense que pierre à
fusil un document faire une vieille
ligne ça qui date d'il ya 1 8 9 ans
lorsque même denis coderre la ville
disait l'époque où il était au parlement
fédéral comme libéral mais là le maire
de montréal furieux qui dit le
gouvernement conservateur fait de la
petite politique en bloc un déversement
vous avez entendu au sucre dans un
camping terrain c'est peut-être le
premier dossier monsieur colère de la
misère c'est plus de la vente pour les
montréalais parce que de façon réflexe
on le connaît on va l'écouter ci
le gouvernement canadien qui est
vraiment très critique la matière de
science qui pensent que les pierrafeu
d'un documentaire qui essayent de nous
faire la leçon qui veut gagner des
petits points politiques parce qu'ils
sont à la croisée de leur chemin pour
moi j'embarque paul est ce que je fais
par exemple parce que x est au dessus de
tout sur moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est la
santé publique
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de trouver les
options possibles et trouver une
solution par la formation
voilà alors qu'est ce que vous en dites
de ce débat allait mais 8 milliards de
litres d'eaux usées sa frappe
l'imaginaire donc c'est pas pour rien
qu'on en parle qu'on est pris avec une
patate chaude politique
ceci dit si c'est vrai ce que denis
coderre dit qu'il ya un an maintenant
qu'environnement canada les études et
qu'à moins de deux semaines de la date
prévue du déversement soudainement denis
lebel dû coûter que j'ai encore quelques
questions
il ya quelque chose là d'un qui sent la
campagne électorale et un tel
déversement l'eau ont été coupées en
deux mais trois sur le gouvernement
libéral en 2007 nous sommes vraiment
conservateur et on peut penser que c'est
le mode campagne électorale de diverses
mais attention d'abord 2-2 participent à
ce que je sache le bloc québécois et
monsieur marqueur donc le npd qui ont
dit si c'était moi je regarde s'ils
n'ont donc qui ont mis en cause de
georges avec les amateurs
monsieur trudeau une somme a été un
petit peu plus diplomatie ça prouve
qu'on a pas mis assez d'argent mais des
franchement pour avoir couvert jean
charest et lucien bouchard nommément
comme minus l'environnement et avoir vu
denis colère quand il était ministre
l'immigration ou des supports d'amateurs
s'il était minus l'environnement
campagne aujourd'hui d'une exactement la
même chose à d'autres choses il ya une
délicate ironie devoir d'une kader dire
ils font de la petite politique moi j'ai
jamais fait ça
monsieur qui damon y voilà n'oublions
pas que l'accueil
outre le fait qu on est en campagne
électorale le gouvernement ne veut pas
avoir un tapis se glisser sous ses pieds
ça peut devenir ça il ya aussi une
petite vengeance qui se mange froid là
toi tu te promènes avec des pipelines
qui tu fais pas de politique je regarde
ma montre et on s'assure de politique
bon on s'en rend pas parce qu'il a
besoin du feu vert de tahoua malgré tout
là
les paroles paroles mais il a besoin je
feu vert de melle pour et de l'avoir
genre le vin belle date des élections
comme à ses 18 d'ailleurs cadette la
veille des élections et des versements
sont pourtant de deux jours bon on parle
de sondages messieurs dames où est-ce
qu'on peut parler de minuit luis oddo a
plutôt que chantal on vous avait amené
une information monsieur un peu gêné
entrevue radio qui viennent de renom
dont qui explore la voix québécois c'est
à dire d'interdire que des
fonctionnaires portent le niqab donc ça
va plus loin que la cérémonie le citoyen
oui il dit je vais essayer de cité au
texte
il se fait demander ce que vous
envisageriez d'étendre votre idée
d'interdiction le niqab
la fonction publique fédérale et il
répond c'est quelque chose que nous
examinons il ya un projet de loi à
l'étude au québec en ce moment et nous
l'examinons et là je vous dis tout de
suite les salles de rédaction de toronto
et d'ailleurs sont en train de s'enfuir
mais là dessus parce que ça va le signal
que ça envoie c'est pas juste au québec
que ça a l'air de marcher et moi ce que
j'en conclu c'est que ça doit être un
filon qui profite vraiment conservateur
parce que ce faisant monsieur un peu
délibérément élargi ce début d'année
leur mère dans le paysage pour d'ici à
la fin de la campagne
tony clément qui sont présidence conseil
du trésor qui gère les fonctionnaires
ont reçu exactement la même question au
printemps après le premier jugement
confédéral il dit il ya en est pas
question
on va pas légiférer là dessus seulement
citoyens est une chose mais les
fonctionnaires d'une autre chose là que
stephen harper dise on étudie la
question
y a pas dit je vérifierai là-dessus
confirmant sa maturité j'étudie la
question c'est clair qu'un lien direct
avec la remontée qui ont eu dans les
sondages après cette question là c'est
évident qu'on ne laisse pas échapper
beaucoup de choses qui ne sont pas
tactiquement payant c'est et descendre
ici aussi c'est que au québec il sent
qu'il peut gagner des sièges mais à
l'extérieur aussi qui peut gagner avec
cette question à ce qu'indiquait à ces
sondages auxquels les derniers sondages
au canada
sont un petit peu plus bas qu'au québec
mais le mot clé ici c'est un petit peu
au vraiment plus bas c'est 70 % au
québec c'est le 10 mai - gavalda 75 % le
niveau d'appui dans les sondages ce
niveau qui baisse par contre quand on
parle du fait que les gens s'identifient
à leur faut faire attention quand même
monsieur harper selon moi c'est
embarquent sur un terrain glissant mais
il doit penser qu'une la garde quand
même il peut être payant glissant mais
peut-être pays et ça doit y croire
les libéraux qui sont les plus
d'identifier hors québec à l'autre
option sont remontées à l'expérience
parce que ça c'est l'autre mystère de
plusieurs séminaires payer apparemment
on verra peut-être pas que seul
évidemment mais a payé assez cher sa
position se barricadent au québec
jeu trop doux ou québec ne pas payer la
même position identifié à la charte
parce que son électorat et vous le voyez
dans les intentions de vote sont
électeurs se reconnaît dans la position
de justin trudeau
c'est un électorat qui le parti libéral
comme la partie de la charte va aider le
choc de la clientèle libéral justin
trudeau avait découvert qu'il la chasse
à des intéressés - les promotions
mulcair ça a été aussi un révélateur
pour certaines choses il s'est fait
accuser dès le début de la campagne et
par trudeau et part du chef de dire il
se voit même chose en français en
anglais ce quelqu'un à qui on peut pas
faire confiance et le pouls plusieurs
québécois qui avaient voté pour le npd
la sphère du niqab comme été un
révélateur ils pensent pas comme moi
finalement et c'est là l'effet combiné
des deux à mon avis va se faire dire
qu'on est un visage à deux faces en
politique on peut pas survivre assez
longtemps et à ce jour je comprends pas
pourquoi monsieur maker pas répondu à ça
dès le début comme s'ils avaient déçu
plusieurs clips exactement qu'il le
pensait sur cette question-là ailleurs
alors que trudeau on sait qu'il est déjà
là sur une victoire et qui a peut-être
pas donné de raison
la aux gens qui ont décroché de rester
accroché au npd sont disciplinés on
détermine jeu car même mois voire
quelques secondes
le nano cela on est habitué à cette
émission bon attention de vente au
canada
ça bouge pas beaucoup depuis hier
mercredi par deux autres
oui c'est ce que j'allais tir mais cette
avancée libéraux est contredite par deux
sens à ces jours ci la touche seul à
avoir le pas à battre les libéraux en
avance en dehors de la marge d'erreur
alors il faut temporiser c'est ce qu'on
voulait vous entendre il s'est fait
l'écho aujourd'hui suggère même que des
conservateurs sont à égalité avec le npd
en tête au québec que je vous dis ça je
suis je voulais me bats pas pour super
lot mais je vous disais ils s'étaient
entassées leurs pis on parle ou maisons
de sondage c'est ça manque c'est un
enfer cette campagne là pour eux mais je
ne sais c'est une boîte à surprises tout
soit avec nous parce que vous êtes à
siby si la survie littoral bon on va se
reparler d'ici là de toute façon des
soldats où il faut vraiment qu à froch
quelques manières de sortir du plateau
aux allures de cauchemar à la pause en
vie et tout de suite